all right let's just jump into the story
explosion at University of Pittsburgh
transgender debate causes safety
emergency as protesters Yellen chant one
protester set fire to a cardboard cutout
with a conservative commentator's face
on it according to the Pittsburgh
Post-Gazette do they have the burning
and Effigy in this article
they have the protests they don't they
don't but uh yes Michael so you are
going to be debating uh at the
University on trans transgender issues I
guess the the other the professor backed
out and then far left extremists set
fire set fires and burned you an effigy
this entire debate got more absurd by
the day because I was invited by isi the
Intercollegiate Studies Institute to
debate this professor uh Donald
McCloskey who now goes by Deirdre he has
transitioned
this is a very respected Professor this
guy is three degrees from Harvard he's
got half a dozen honorary doctors he's
got two dozen academic Publications
I am but a lowly podcaster I have no
particularly Advanced degree I've
written two books only one of them has
words in it okay the professor should
have been down to debate the professor
didn't like me from the beginning
especially because of my CPAC speech
called me a fascist called me an
anti-jesus Catholic what I guess he's
Episcopalian or something I really don't
need to be lectured on theology by
Episcopalian but but yeah yeah he he
identifies that way at least but he he
said even though Knowles is terrible
it's important that we debate these
issues and he kept sort of insulting my
intelligence we had a pre-debate call
just a few weeks ago in which he
reiterated his desire to debate and then
a week or so before the debate he pulls
out and he pulled out because he's
intelligent and I think he realized that
not even a guy with three Harvard
degrees and a whole bunch of honorary
doctorates could defend this
indefensible idea I think he also may
have pulled out because he realized that
I'm not just a provocateur bomb thrower
like the literal bomb throwers that were
outside of the building that he I think
he just realized I'm kind of relatively
polite and we were just going to debate
these issues he couldn't do it and so
Brad Palumbo the libertarian leaning uh
I guess he would call himself a
conservative but he's a very left on
LGBT issues he he filled in and I give
him a lot of credit for Pinch hitting
and allowing this debate to go on but
but even with Brad who's relatively
moderate on these issues relatively to
today where we're chopping off little
kids genitals uh the the protesters were
just absolutely nuts and uh and they did
everything they could to shut it down
they tried to burn me an effigy they did
bring it well I guess they did burn me
an effigy but here I am baby I'm not
burned at all what was it you said
before that angered these people that
with transgenderism needed to be
eradicated the concept of trans that's
right I don't I probably haven't been on
the show since the CPAC speech yeah I
said I've now memorized this quote
because it's come up in the news so much
for the good of society and especially
for the good of the poor people who've
Fallen prey to this confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life the whole Preposterous
ideology at every level so how do you
but let's clarify that you you were
literally talking about gender ideology
you weren't talking about people oh of
course so I said it's an ism first of
all refers to a set of beliefs and then
lest there be any confusion I clarified
in the parenthetical immediately I said
it's a Preposterous ideology I said for
the good of the people who have this
confusion so presumably I don't want to
murder these people there was no way to
misinterpret what I said which is why
the left-wing media just changed my
words so The Daily Beast Rolling Stone
they defamed me they they admitted they
defamed me because they ultimately
changed the headlines you know fly gets
halfway around the world before the
truth catches it we have the the video
of Michael knows oh wow actually from
Tim cast news
um right out of his neck and chest it's
neck and chest we'll say it is an effigy
and so I just I just asked you right
right uh I just look at this kind of
stuff and I wonder is the intention here
to intimidate because the end I mean the
answer is simply put yes or black magic
yeah who knows black magic also to
intimidate my soul but you're you're
using a very specific word there Tim why
would you why would you use that word
because we got a story earlier that uh
in Charlottesville they they're
indicting the tiki torch Marchers and uh
they say it's because they burned
something with the intent to intimidate
and it's like dude come on we know what
that bill is supposed to be the law is
supposed to be about supposed to be
about like someone putting a cross in
your yard and sitting on a fire not
walking down the sidewalk setting a
cigarette yeah exactly saying dumb
things holding it a tiki torch which
keeps mosquitoes away and and and here's
the thing right I I I hold that group in
a similar disdain to as I hold these
these groups both are out of their Free
Speech but as you see law enforcement
goes in Only One Direction I mean it's
kind of a weird thing because
they're identitarians the same as the
white nationalists but for Like A
different race so I actually don't view
their ideologies as different for the
most part you know that's kind of weird
well nobody is intimidated by either
these people burning you an effigy
because they look ridiculous and nobody
was intimidated realistically by the
tiki torch Marchers in Charlottesville
wearing white polo shirts
when they were throwing
explosives at the wall that I didn't
feel worried because again we take
security very seriously but that is a
somewhat intimidating action when
they're throwing explosives
persuasion I would definitely call it
intimidation this is what I'm tired of
I'm tired of the the attempt by the
so-called moderate individuals I
consider myself fairly moderate right
but I've heard this over and over again
when I was in Berkeley someone someone
took uh I think was an M80 and threw it
in the air and it landed next to an old
woman and exploded and she fell down and
I said someone just threw an explosive
at this old lady and they're oh come on
it's a firecracker and I don't know
okay
not playing that game yeah it's an
explosive did it explode it exploded
m80s are not like little poppers can
take your fingers off yeah you can take
your whole hand off and so this woman
like Falls over
they also take these mortar shells which
are like the size of maybe tennis balls
maybe a little bit smaller and when they
explode they spray like everyone's seen
fireworks when they go up in the air and
then it blossoms yeah imagine that on
the ground those are explosives and you
get these people on first of all the
left will of course call them
firecrackers because they want to
minimize the language but then you'll
get people online being like look I
don't look antifa but those are just
flowers no explosives and it's like okay
see what happens one of those goes off
next to your head right they're both
your fireworks and explosives yeah it's
fireworks are explosives of course but
but just to clarify I'll call it a
firework if you put it in a tube and it
launches into the air and it looks
pretty I'll call an explosive when
you're trying to kill people with it
yeah like a knife isn't a murder tool
unless you kill somebody with it yeah
like exactly it's if if if I went to a
steakhouse this past weekend and I love
it when they walk up and they say your
knife sir and you get to pick one you
ever see I've ever had that happen it's
like the second time in my life and I'm
like I'll take this one he's not handing
me a murder weapon he's handing me a
utensil however if someone one took that
and killed somebody it would then be in
a bag labeled to murder weapon
difference so Michael I gotta ask how do
you based on this this quote that kind
of set this all In Motion about
eradicating transgenders and probably
those two words are pretty extreme to
have near each other but how do you
balance that with transgender people in
your love or care for people that happen
to be going through what they're going
through well there is no such
ontological category as transgender
people that there are people who are
confused about their sex but the whole
point is that there is no such thing as
a man who is secretly a woman that's
that's a false anthropology and this is
why the libs had to lie about what I
said and change my words and throw
explosives at me and burn me an effigy
because they have no answer to that
because we all know that that's true we
all know that these men are not actually
women and we're just lying to them to
varying degrees and this was I think the
weakest part of Brad Palumbo's argument
last night at Pitt was he tried to have
a moderate position which is okay these
men are not actually women but we should
treat them as women in the bathrooms but
not on the sports teams and we should do
it to the 19 year olds but not the 17
year olds and it it just is so arbitrary
either men can really be women or they
can and and that was that was why the
left reacted so much to my speech
because the libs thought that they had
won on the issue of transgenderism no
one took this thing seriously 10 years
ago now it is enshrined in our law and
they thought that they won and they
thought that the debate over
transgenderism was now going to be
should we trans the seven year olds or
should we wait till they turn eight and
in my speech I said no guys there's no
uncertain issues there's a middle ground
like taxes we can come to a middle
agreement on immigration what's the
right number of immigrants
either women have bathrooms or they
don't have bathrooms the minute you let
a man into the woman's bathroom the
women lose their bathroom so we gotta we
gotta pick one but I think there is a
moderate solution to that it just single
single room bathrooms right you could
abolish women's bathrooms altogether but
some women might might say you know the
issue isn't that we don't have enough
bathrooms out there because this is the
other the other people they'll say well
we just need another sports team for the
transgenders but it's going to be we
obviously we'll need two more sports
teams one for the female to male
transgenders and one for the male to
feel so how many how many questions I
just agree a little bit I mean I don't
care we make whatever League you want
you can make uh if they made a league
where it's like a basketball team with
five players and one of them has to be a
woman and we'll call it the uh the the
the four the one in four teams League I
don't care make up whatever League you
want the idea for me uh I'll go back to
the bathroom thing too I'm at the
airport this past weekend and they have
men's room women's room and then all
gender in the middle guess which
bathroom I used all gender you know why
it's a big press private room I'm like
this is fantastic I can take my coat off
I can hang it up I got like a big mirror
to myself watchman's I I think it's
fantastic this used to be called family
bath that's right they just changed the
label fair point though there's always a
huge line coming out of the women's
bathroom so taking that bathroom away
and giving them a single room is
probably gonna make things probably
gonna have to just turn the whole
airport into a bunch of individual
single small bathrooms my issue is uh
when it comes to female sports is that
we did not create women's leagues
because sometimes people wear dresses we
created women's leagues because
biological females have different
physical characteristics and want to
compete amongst themselves without men
yeah so all of a sudden now the debate
becomes well is a trans woman a woman
then they can compete on the wins team
but it's like no no hold on if you're
making the argument that woman just
refers to social constructs let me just
remind you we did not create the WNBA
because sometimes people wear dresses
real quick because the women playing
basketball in the WNBA are wearing the
same jerseys that guys wear like the
social constructs don't play it's so
important I think to to say like a boy
is a boy and if he becomes a trans girl
or trans woman he's still a boy that is
a trans woman like you never stop being
a boy you never stop being a human
you're still a human that identifies as
a carrot or whatever or a man that
identifies as a woman but it's still a
man and a trans woman together you can
be both but right but you're right Ian
and the issue is they they reject that I
don't know I've never really had a deep
conversation with someone that is there
isn't one this is the problem with it is
every time that I've tried to engage in
a conversation with a serious person I'm
not just talking about some clout
chasing YouTubers or whatever I'm
talking I wanted the most serious
pro-trans person there was I got the
best Professor for it and he pulled out
of the debate isi then invited like a
dozen people who are big in the
transgender movement none of them would
because they can't debate it but here's
the correct unit it is I think
I've thought about these issues gun
control assault weapons what is a woman
things like that and I feel like I've
done a better job articulating what
their position should be of course the
issue is and you could probably do the
same you could better articulate an
argument on their behalf but if you're
being consistent you're being logical
and honest you arrive more in a position
where we are you say okay I can't make
those arguments well there's just no way
to make it work because they make a lot
of mutually contradictory arguments on
the one hand they'll say well
transgenderism is when your true self
doesn't align with your body but but so
I guess your soul is female but your
body is man I believe in Souls but but
they also don't believe in Souls so then
they'll make a materialist argument
they'll say okay well no it's actually
your body is male but your brain is
female which first of all is based on
just complete bunk science and they're
interesting they're interesting ways to
debunk the methodological issues in
those in those studies but I think that
was formally debunked though to be
honest there was a yeah I remember uh
there was a big issue with
transracialism
um like seven years ago and people were
we're trying to use this idea that a
brain could be male or female and the
body could be different as the
explanation and then something happened
where an academic created a transracial
argument saying that individuals who
have let's say a person is like 2.7
percent Asian and they present white
they may have within their minds that
they're actually Asians and the left
went and lost it because now Earth whoa
no white people aren't you can't do that
and so that kind of broke the whole life
the other reason the brain studies are
crazy is one men and women's Brains are
a little bit different but the problem
is the studies when they're looking at
the brains they're looking at people
generally who have been on these
cross-sex hormones forever so you can't
know if the hormones themselves are
changing the brain makeup also the way
in which the brains are a little bit
different say the brain of a trans woman
from a man uh the the difference does
not make the brain look like a female
brain it makes it look like a little bit
different entirely and so there are all
sorts of problems with that but but even
then the problem with their argument is
your brain is part of your body they're
just so you're saying part of my body is
male but the other part is female but it
doesn't actually show up on the skin it
just doesn't make sense here's what
confused me with all of it the question
what is a woman
I can easily answer the question for the
left but they can't answer their own
question I don't quite understand what
so what is the what would you think the
leftist definition of woman is a human
who identifies as an adult human female
because and and it wasn't hard for me to
think that like they said female is sex
and woman is social construct and I said
okay so if someone's a woman they're
identifying as a biological female yeah
but not but not right how come not one
leftist has ever said that sentence
that's it's a great point because it it
remains kind of circular but in a
Charming way this is why I I don't even
really love the right it's the social
construct argument yeah attached to
biology right but I I don't even just
love the biological argument because I
sort of think it partakes of the Same
Soul denying scientism that got us in
this mess in the first place you know if
the answer to what is a woman is 2x
chromosomes in a womb I think well you
know I think there's more to it than
that man maybe sugar spice and
everything nice a woman is much more
than her body but a woman is at the very
least her body and it's not like this is
a brand new question that cropped up we
do have thousands and thousands of years
of very sophisticated thinking on what
kind constitutes a man what constitutes
a woman but the moment you try to engage
in that conversation the transgenderists
run away because there there is no way
to defend it the big divide I see here
is not between the men and women and the
trans and the whatever the opposite of
trans is it's between people who view
human Humanity as being made up of
intellect and will got an intellect so I
can perceive the truth and I've got a
will so I can act on it and the people
on the left who say forget that
intellect stuff it's all about the will
well I think what I'm thinking that this
is where I keep going to I think what's
happening is there's the the Catholic
the the Christian conservative that says
that a spirit impregnated Jesus's mother
that somehow and it's like I'm into
reality so if a guy's gonna say a boy is
a girl I'm into reality a boy is a boy
and Spirits do not impregnate women you
need male sperm yeah well no I mean the
the Virgin birth did happen and the
incarnations the pivot of history but
you're right one of those things is
Fantastical but it was the miracle that
that uh directs the entire course of
history what's happening is disciple
that are identifying as a woman that as
a man is like well they say that ghosts
can impregnate people so much
the god itself categories of male and
female altogether they're denying that
there are natural laws Miracles are just
things that happen that deviate from the
natural laws seemingly for Supernatural
reasons but you've got to admit but God
could impregnate a woman's body is
mythical that's Fantastical why I I I I
think that you're in two separate
categories and you're conflating these
things I'm trying to find a solution
between the magical things but they're
not explaining to you God is omnipotent
right God is the Creator God is outside
of time and space and the Mystery of the
Incarnation is that God the Divine logic
of the universe the logos takes on human
flesh and dwells Among Us and uh this is
the pivot of history now the reason this
is not magical thinking is God being
defined as the maximally great being as
omnipotent can do do what he Wills
especially as he is logic itself
a little boy is not God a little boy is
not omnipotent and or a 25 year old man
for that matter and so when a 25 year
old man says I'm actually a woman and
comes up with some cockamami
explanations to why that is that can't
make sense now I'm not I'm not insisting
that you believe in God but I I am
pointing out that if you if you
acknowledge that some things are better
than other things and that an
intelligible World probably implies an
intelligence that created the world
that's outside of time and space then
the existence of Miracles is not
something that's crazy or unbelievable
that would not naturally follow I'll
just address it for you I Ian if a boy
was witnessed by uh let's say let's just
say a young man 20 years old
six foot tall
walked into a a town center walked into
Columbus Circle in in New York City and
ever and hundreds of people gathered
around and then he went something
strange is happening and then
transformed into a woman that's a
miracle right yeah but that's that's
never that's impossibility and that that
exactly is the difference between your
argument when someone comes out and says
that they can undergo surgery and
they're now a woman they're not they're
a man I agree with that but I also I
believe in God all right so hold on the
difference is the left is not making the
argument that a man magically
transformed by power of God into a woman
they're arguing that they can surgically
change their bodies or medically and
that makes them the same as someone who
was born they're arguing that it's not
Supernatural that it's actually just a
natural fact of the world I feel like
the argument is they're saying green is
red when I want it to be red and I'm
saying well let's just be real green is
green red is red and you're right the
difference between that and say like
faith-based miracle-believing they're
just different categories I don't know I
don't think so I mean they're definitely
different categories but different ways
of kind of taking leaps of assumption
about things that I think are apparently
impossible I I've seen I've never seen
an inkling of evidence that is that God
could impregnate a human body well I
that you're talking about faith versus
denying it's also I just think it's also
faith transgenderism is Faith it's it's
it but look I can only I can only say it
like one more time it's not the same
thing it's not the same but I'm trying
to find a through line for in a solution
but it's not I think you're attaching
two things that don't come together
you're mesmerized by a a central miracle
in the history of the world the pivot of
history but are you saying let's put
that aside for a moment are you saying
that no Miracles can happen you think
the idea of Miracles itself is is uh
impossible well Miracle how would you
define Miracle a uh suspension of the
natural laws in a way that is improbable
and fantastic that is possible because
we're still learning what the natural
laws are as we've gained
but I've never seen any evidence let me
try it this way uh is it possible we
live in a simulation yeah could the
person in control the simulation alter
the code on a whim to say impregnate a
woman yeah but you got to save the
possibility of being in a simulation is
near zero as actually closer to one I
would say the point you know 100 million
trillion but but let's not deviate
let's assume that we're in a simulation
it's possible that's a bet not a good
assumption because that is a very
unlikely you're just trying to avoid
answers you have any evidence but okay
go for it yeah didn't you you already
granted the possibility it is um
simulation theory is is possible uh
there are many smart thinkers uh the
easiest one is Elon Musk that's so
famous who believe that if it is
possible to create a universe to
simulate a universe based on our current
here's here's the idea based on our
current level of Technology we have
created such vast virtual worlds in 30
years with the Advent of the technology
it is likely that in another 30 years
we'll be able to create things
indistinguishable from reality
considering where deep fakes are at
already yeah we're only probably 10
years away from being able to render on
the Fly universes
yeah so if assuming at most 10 years
most I mean yeah that might be a little
long yeah with deep fakes already the
point where they can make Joe Rogan say
whatever they want him to say and even
show his him there was a commercial of
Joe Rogan selling a product because they
just typed into computer press enter and
it rendered a video now imagine they had
to do the exact same thing but using 3D
modeling like
um Unity or something Unreal Engine or
something like that it would not we're
only a few years away from that so this
is the argument about stimulism that's
if it is possible for us to do in only a
few years there's a strong likelihood we
actually exist in such a universe but I
don't want to deviate too far my point
is just that I don't like that analogy
by the way I don't like that that belief
that if we might do it in the future if
it's likely that we'll do in the future
that it already happened doesn't make
sense but you already granted the point
Ian right that Miracles are possible but
possible it's a strange word because
point zero trillionth of a percent
possible but you're just making enough
of it but also the words Miracles
you're making up that stuff you might
see a crack of lightning it looks like a
guy's face a miracle is a supernatural
event and not a natural event but a
supernatural but but Ian you are making
up that probability that's not it oh no
no absolutely none of us can quantify
simply put there is a difference okay
I'll put it this way you make a video
game you as the programmer can decide
you're playing The Sims you can
literally lift the person up put them in
a bathroom and get rid of the door you
can do that as the person in control of
this year I'll Grant you this there
might be a technology in the future
where you can vibrate a woman's womb
it's not that you're you're completely
misunderstood always get to the
vibrations when I'm when I'm programming
a video game I can just right click
insert object and manifest a goblin
there's no point at which I have to find
a person and then draw on him and make
him no like when you're programming
something you can just put it there when
you're playing Fallout and you want to
build a treehouse you click a button
boom The Treehouse appears there's a
difference between you being a
programmer who can make something happen
and in the game a character deciding
they are not what you made them
there there's there's a it's a very good
analogy yeah if the power goes out good
luck convincing anyone we're in a
simulation like we're we're like
fantasizing about some ridiculous
possibility because we have electricity
is is that I'm not trying to fantasize
I'm trying to point out that arguing
someone who is biologically male who's
who you can observe their DNA under an
electron microscope NC they have X and Y
chromosomes coming out and saying
actually after the surgery they're now
female because this is one component of
this you're not I was at a uh I I often
mention I'm saying at poker tables
because that tends to be what I'm doing
on the weekends there's a dealer and
someone brought up on the TV they were
having a discussion about men and female
sports and the dealer said something and
like it was kind of obvious the dealer
was not taking kindly to all of these 30
to 40 year old men who are not happy
with this they were grumbling about it
and then I said something like uh the
dealer said transgender females and I
said no no you mean transgender males a
transgender female is a trans man and a
transgender male is a trans woman and he
was like no wait what no he got upset
about it the point is
if someone is female
and they are transgender they are they
are they have a womb they have breasts
but they want to exhibit the
characteristics of a male that is a
trans man what's happened now is the
left is conflating they are saying
female and and woman mean the same thing
now so you'll often hear people say
transgender female to refer to a
biological male Who Wants To Be A a
woman right they're confusing the
language it was it has to be confused
because there's no argument for it and
to your point Ian you're saying well I
don't like magical thinking on the left
so I don't want magical thinking on the
right either but the difference here is
there are many good Arguments for the
existence of God and then we can get
into miracles from the existence of God
but there are many good argue I could
give you a five right now I could
probably give you ten right now and
there are no good Arguments for
transgenderism and and so this is why we
have theology this is why we've had very
wise men for thousands of years
discussing this in a recent way and this
is why not even a esteemed scholar on
transgender will show up to debate this
issue so I think if we just follow logic
you you might choose not to believe in
the Miracles you might choose not to
believe in God even but there's a
logical argument for that there is no
logical life God is logical at this
state with quantum physics and the
ability to see Cosmic microwave
background radiation it looks like a
neural pattern and that's that's what
Michael's saying about logos in the
embodia yeah it is it seems like
waveformer waves but I was targeted I
want a sentient waveform doesn't
necessarily mean that these Miracles
were real just because someone told me
that I I but I I just wanna I'll make
one more point we're gonna move to
another story oh my gosh let's talk
about this all night no it's just
because you're saying the same thing
over and over it's important because I
think the people the transgender
Community is not taking your stuff
seriously because of that kind of just
accept it but but you're no look I read
a book when I was 19 years old that um I
would say made me believe in God I've
talked told the stories about the
conversations I've had with people who
are religious when I view myself as an
atheist and the book that I actually
read was about quantum physics and uh uh
putting electrons through conductors and
then trapping them to simulate elements
in and things of that nature and the
prospect that we could create
one-dimensional sheets of an element
that by and then by altering the amount
of electrons we push through the
conductors we could change the elemental
properties and things like that I
started reading that stuff and then it
made me start to think about the
universe think about simulation Theory
and logic and then I was like oh wow
like I'm starting to see a bigger
picture here understanding that there is
like we are we are in some kind of
logical system the universe uh it's hard
to quantify to be completely honest well
it's the very fact that you're speaking
in a way that is intelligible to me
presupposes that there is such a thing
as logic outside of ourselves and it
implies an intelligent grid I want to
make sure I get this one before they try
and take a clip my point is humans write
math we then create equations and solve
problems and humans have a degree of
understanding of math that is not a
human creation it is humans mapping the
logic of the universe meaning the logic
of the universe exists to a massive
degree well beyond our comprehension and
we have a tiny little flashlight that
we're pointing in the dark and writing
down what we see it's possible that
after billions of years humans create
this big huge uh Quantum Blackboard
showing all of the code that we would
describe of the universe and that is the
logic or whatever you describe it as but
we can only see a tiny piece of it it's
real it exists and we're mapping it out
within the confines of that to say
something like yes this thing is
discernably wood it's a it's a word we
use to describe this carbon structure
I've decided to smoke
that that doesn't do anything you can't
and here's another example two plus two
equals five they say well no it doesn't
and I've it's funny because when I was a
teenager I actually got into an argument
with a friend of mine who was in high
school and they were teaching this back
then I I she told me one plus one does
not equal two that's a social construct
and I said what are you talking about no
it isn't and I was like I have a pen in
this hand I grabbed pants off her table
and I was like here's a pen here's a pen
I have one pen here one pen here there's
two pens in my hand there will never be
a circumstance where that is three pens
yeah and then she's like you don't
understand and I was like no I don't
think you understand thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time